a volte ho paura che si rompa il mio
cuore ancora e ancora poi ti avvicini
tuo
con il tuo visino e la tua luce ti dirò che lo sono
la tua bambina voglio campioni per il tutto
la vita e quello che vuoi ma se mi ami
bene, qui baciami se puoi oh oh oh
Mi scuso se quello che ti do non lo è
tanto amore ma per noi lo è
quello che voglio e ti amo di più oh oh tu
Mi scuso se quello che ti do non è molto
amore
ma per noi tu sei cosa
Ti amo e ti amo moltissimo
ti amo tanto
Voglio così tanto
nessuno
da quando ti ho incontrato mi piace sorridere e
Anche se piove, sarò felice se
Ti guardo e voglio andare dove
essere
su di me oh oh oh chiedo perdono se
quello che ti do non è molto amore ma per
noi siamo quello che voglio e tu
Voglio di più, oh, oh, mi scuso se lo faccio
quello che ti do non è molto amore ma per
noi esseri quello che voglio e tu
Voglio così tanto
ti amo tanto
[Musica]
chiedo scusa
Dico per il nostro amore oh oh oh tu vuoi
quello che voglio e ti amo moltissimo
che io sono il tuo limite è il nostro
la facilità è che vuoi quello che voglio e
ti amo
e tu
Voglio
ti amo tanto